>>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN PETER
MEIJER OF MICHIGAN
CONGRATULATING TRUMP BACKED
OPPONENT JOHN GIBBS WHO NARROWLY
DEFEATED HIM IN THIS WEEK'S
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
>> THIS WAS -- THIS WAS A
HARD-FOUGHT RACE, DECIDED BY
LESS THAN 4,000 VOTES OUT OF
OVER 100,000 CAST.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS, YOU KNOW, A
LONG RACE, BUT A RACE THAT JOHN
RAN VERY WELL.
I JUST WANT TO NOW OFFICIALLY
INTRODUCE, SEND MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND WISHING THE
BEST OF LUCK IN ALL THAT IS TO
COME.
>> MEYER WAS ONE OF THE TEN
HOUSE REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
OPPONENT RECEIVED A MAJOR
FUNDRAISING BOOST FROM
DEMOCRATS.
JOINING US NOW SINCE THE PRIME
CERTIFICATE IS CONGRESS PETER
MEIJER FROM MICHIGAN.
YOU FOUGHT THE GOOD FIGHT.
YOU REPRESENTED YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND YOUR CONSCIENCE
AND DEFENDED DEMOCRACY BUT YOU
CAME UP SHORT IN THIS PARTISAN
PRIMARY.
IT WAS CLOSE, LESS THAN 4,000
VOTE MARGIN SEPARATED YOU FROM
YOUR OPPONENT.
SO DO YOU THINK THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE'S MAJOR AD BUY IN THE
LAST WEEK OF THE CAMPAIGN MADE
THE DECISIVE DIFFERENCE IN YOUR
PRIMARY?
>> GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
I WILL BE HONEST, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW.
I CAN MONDAY MORNING QUARTERBACK
ALL DAY LONG.
I'M NOT HERE TO WHINE ABOUT THE
DCCC COMING IN AND MEDDLING, BUT
JUST TO POINT OUT THAT ANY PARTY
THAT PRETENDS TO HAVE A SET OF
PRINCIPLES, ANY PARTY THAT
PRETENDS TO HAVE A SET OF VALUES
AND THAT COMES IN AND BOOSTS
EXACTLY THE SAME TYPE OF
CANDIDATE THAT THEY CLAIM IS A
FEAR TO -- A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY, DON'T EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO HOLD ON TO THAT SENSE OF
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS AND SAINGT
MOAN, DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE
REPUBLICANS WHO WILL LOOK AT
THAT AND SAY I KNOW I'M GOING TO
GET HEAT FROM MY OWN SIDE, I
NEVER EXPECTED THE OTHER SIDE TO
AS WELL DOUBLE DOWN IN A CYNICAL
PLOY TO PUT FORWARD THE
CANDIDATE THEY THINK IS LESS
ELECTABLE.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE IN IN
MOMENT, AND THIS IS NOT WHY I
WANT TO COMPLAIN ABOUT MY OWN
DEFEAT, I LOST, THAT'S ON ME,
BUT THAT IS TO SAY WHAT TYPE OF
A SYSTEM ARE WE GOING TO HAVE IF
CANDIDATES STEP FORWARD AND
REALIZE THEY CAN BE EJECTED BY
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE TO TRY TO
BE A PRODUCTIVE MEMBER.
THAT YOU WILL NEVER FIND ANY
SEMBLANCE OF COMFORT OR SAFETY
IN DOING THE JOB, THAT IT ALL
WILL COME DOWN TO PARTISAN
BENEFIT NO MATTER WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCE.
>> WHAT'S THE POINT I REALLY
WANT TO GET TO TODAY BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, VOTERS WANT GOVERNMENT
TO WORK, BUT THESE PARTISAN
EXTREMES DON'T, AND THERE'S A
CONTRADICTION THERE.
BUT JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE WE PLAYED YOUR COMMENTS
TO -- YOUR GRACIOUS COMMENTS TO
YOUR OPPONENT AT THE TOP.
HE PROMOTED NOT ONLY TRUMP'S
LIES BUT A BOAT LOAD OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
WAS THIS JUST GOOD SPORTSMANSHIP
ON YOUR PART OR IS IT AN
OUTRIGHT ENDORSEMENT?
>> I HOLD THE SEAT THAT GERALD
FORD HELD FROM 1949 TO 1973 AND
I THINK WHAT WOULD FORD HAVE
DONE IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES?
I FIND IT IRONIC THAT MANY ON
THE ANTI-TRUMP SIDE OF THE AISLE
ARE FRUSTRATED THAT I DIDN'T ACT
LIKE DONALD TRUMP AND THAT I
CONCEDED THE ELECTION.
THAT I WASN'T A SORE LOSER.
THAT I CONGRATULATED MY
OPPONENT.
TO ME THAT IS JUST BEING A
CIVIL, COURTEOUS PERSON AND
SHOULD BE THE BARE MINIMUM WE
EXPECT OF THOSE WHO ARE IN OUR
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT, RATHER
THAN ACTING EXACTLY LIKE THE
TYPE OF POLITICS THAT I FRANKLY
STAND AGAINST.
>> WELL, CIVILITY IS SOMETHING
WE ALL NEED TO SEE MORE OF AND I
THINK YOU'VE REPRESENTED THAT
TIME AND AGAIN.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT -- THE
POLITICAL INCENTIVE STRUCTURE
THAT YOU CALLED OUT AND TALK
ABOUT HOW TO CONFRONT IT, BUT
FIRST I WANT YOU TO TAKE US
BEHIND THE SCENES.
YOU WERE ONE OF TEN LONELY HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED YOUR
CONSCIENCE AND THE PARTISAN
PRIMARY STRUCTURE IS SET UP
AGAINST YOU IN SOME WAY, BUT I
WONDER TAKE US BEHIND THE
SCENES.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HEAR YOUR
CONGRESSIONAL COLLEAGUES
PRIVATELY SAY THAT THEY KNOW
DONALD TRUMP IS LYING, THEY KNOW
HE LOST THE ELECTION, BUT THEY
ARE AFRAID TO SAY SO FOR THEIR
POLITICAL CAREER OR THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY?
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HEAR THAT?
>> WELL, I'M NOT THE FIRST TO
HAVE SAID T BUT IF WE HAD SECRET
BALLOTS IN CONGRESS MORE OFTEN,
I THINK YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED
BY WHAT THE RESULTS WOULD SHOW.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
FRANKLY THAT'S THE CASE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
AND THE NEED TO IMPEACH ON THE
ONE HAND, WE CAN TALK ABOUT
SUPPORT FOR NANCY PELOSI OR JUST
BELIEF IN SOME OF THE MORE
EXTREME PROGRESSIVE POLICIES ON
THE OTHER.
THE AVERAGE MEMBER OF CONGRESS
IS TRAPPED BETWEEN THEIR
PARTISAN PRIORITIES OF THEIR
PARTY OR KIND OF DOMINANT
OFFICIALS WITHIN IT AND THEN
WHAT SIGNAL THAT SENDS TO THE
MOST PASSIONATE PLURALITIES OF
THE PRIMARY VOTERS, TORN BETWEEN
THAT AND ACTUALLY TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THEIR JOBS.
I THINK I'VE SEEN SO MANY
OFFICIALS IN CONGRESS, I THINK
OF KURT SCHRADER IN ORG EGON WH
HAS TRIED TO PREVENT SOME OF THE
EXCESSES OF HER PARTY, TRYING TO
PREVENT SOME TO WALK THE PLANK
ON UNPOPULAR LEGISLATION THAT
WAS NOT GOING TO PASS.
HE WAS PRIMARIED AND THE SEAT
TILTS OR CHANGES THAT LIKELIHOOD
OF FLIPPING, YOU KNOW, HE HAD A
TOSS-UP SEAT THAT WENT LEAN D, I
WENT A TOSS-UP SEAT THAT WENT
LEAN D.
BOTH PARTIES ARE PLAYING THE
ROLE OF TRYING TO EJECT SOME OF
THE MEMBERS BEST CAPABLE OF
HOLDING OP TO THEIR SEATS AND
THAT IS GOING TO LEAD TO SLIMMER
MAJORITIES, LEAD TO MORE
FLIPPING BETWEEN EXTREMES AND
FRANKLY MORE PARTISAN CHAOS.
>> GIVEN THAT THERE ARE MORE
INDEPENDENTS SELF-SIDE AS
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, THE
MODERATES MAKE UP A PLURALITY OF
VOTERS, BUT THOSE VOTERS FEEL
POLITICALLY HOMELESS.
DO YOU FEEL POLITICALLY HOMELESS
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK CAN BE
DONE TO BRIDGE THESE GAPS?
>> JOHN, I AM A REPUBLICAN, I
HAVE BEEN A REPUBLICAN, I WILL
BE A REPUBLICAN AND MY MOTTO
GOING IN WAS WITH MY SHIELD ON
IT, NOT COMPROMISING ON VALUES
OR PRINCIPLES AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT COULD HAVE A SEVERE
POLITICAL COST, A POLITICAL COST
WHICH I PAID.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TRY TO WORK
WITHIN THE PARTIES THAT WE HAVE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE AREN'T
LARGER STRUCTURAL REFORMS THAT
WOULD ALLOW PARTIES TO TRY TO
HAVE A BIGGER TENT.
I'VE TALKED TO A LOT OF
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR OFFICE
WHO SAY I CONSIDER MYSELF A
REPUBLICAN BUT FIGURE DOWN THE
LAUNDRY LIST OF THINGS THAT I
NEED TO RECITE IN ORDER TO NOT
GET EVISCERATED IN A PRIMARY I
AM NOT WILLING TO DO THAT.
THERE IS URGENT NEED TO
UNDERTAKE SOME OF THAT
STRUCTURAL REFORM.
LOOK AT THE THREE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE ON TRACK TO WIN
REELECTION WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH.
THEY ARE IN JUNGLE OR TOP TWO
PRIMARY STATES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS IN WHICH
HOW CANDIDATES ARE CHOSEN THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW TO APPEAL
TO THE BROADEST SWATH OF THE
ELECTORATE SO THAT WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES WHO ARE TRULY
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE THEY
SERVE.
>> COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
LOOK, YOU PUT COUNTRY OVER
PARTY.
YOU VOTED TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SO IF THERE IS A 2024 REMATCH
BETWEEN BIDEN AND TRUMP, WOULD
YOU VOTE FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
OVER TRUMP?
>> I'VE SAID IT BEFORE, I THINK
IF IN 2024 WE'RE BACK TO A
BIDEN/TRUMP DYNAMIC, IT WILL BE
A PRETTY SAD COMMENTARY ON WHERE
OUR COUNTRY IS.
WE HAVE YOUNG, FRESH, RISING
LEADERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE AND THAT SYMPTOM OF JUST
DEFAULTING TO THE CHOICE THAT
FRANKLY NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT, BUT THEY FEEL, YOU KNOW,
WELL, IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
CAN -- PUT IT THIS WAY, BIDEN
HAS BEATEN TRUMP SO THERE IS A
DEMOCRATIC ARGUMENT THAT IF
TRUMP IS PUT FORWARD BIDEN CAN
BEAT HIM DESPITE BIDEN ALREADY
BEING THE OLDEST PRESIDENT WE
HAVE HAD IN OFFICE AND TRUMP --
BASICALLY ANYONE ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE COULD PROBABLY
BEAT BIDEN.
THAT IS A VERY MESSED UP AND
FRUSTRATING AND DEPRESSING
DYNAMIC WHERE WE'RE JUST
SETTLING FOR THE LOWEST COMMON
ACCEPTABLE DENOMINATOR RATHER
THAN ADVOCATING FOR FOLKS THAT
MAKE PEOPLE PASSIONATE, EXCITED
AND THRILLED ABOUT WHAT THE
FUTURE MAY BRING.
>> SO I'M HEARING YOU NOT ANSWER
THE QUESTION DIRECTLY BUT WHAT
I'M ALSO HEARING IS YOU WOULD
WRITE IN SOMEBODY ELSE AND
SUPPORT SOMEBODY ELSE, YOU WOULD
CHOOSE NONE OF THE ABOVE.
FAIR?
YES OR NO?
>> I DON'T WANT THAT MATCH UP IN
2024.
>> YOU DON'T WANT THAT MATCHUP.
>> ONE FINAL YES OR NO BEFORE WE
GO.
YOU FOUGHT THE GOOD FIGHT, YOU
LOST THE BATTLE.
ARE YOU KEEPING THE DOOR OPEN TO
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AGAIN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M NOT ON THE BALLOT IN 2022,
I'M NOT CAMPAIGNING IN 2022, BUT
I PLAN TO STAY VERY ENGAGED IN
POLITICS AND FRANKLY TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE AN IMPACT
PROBABLY MORE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITHIN WEST MICHIGAN, BUT
CERTAINLY WANTING TO INFLUENCE
THE NATIONAL DIALOGUE AS WELL.
>> CONGRESSMAN PETER MEIJER,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US ON "NEW DAY."
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR EXTRAORDINARY S.E.
CUPP.
>> THANKS.
GREAT INTERVIEW.
>> WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF PETER
MEIJER'S COMMENTS?
>> I'M SO SAD BECAUSE HE'S
EXACTLY THE KIND OF POLITICIAN
WE NEED RIGHT NOW AND FOR FOUR
OR FIVE YEARS I LISTENED TO
DEMOCRATS, RIGHTLY, ADMONISH
REPUBLICANS FOR PUTTING PARTY
OVER COUNTRY, FOR PUTTING TRUMP
OVER COUNTRY, AND I WATCHED THEM
BEG FOR MORE PETER MEIJERS AND
ADAM KINZINGERS AND LIZ CHENEYS
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE BLOOD
MONEY THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
BEHIND FOLKS LIKE PETER MEIJER'S
OPPONENTS, IT'S LIKE REDRAWING
ADAM KINZINGER'S DISTRICT SO
THAT HE EFFECTIVELY COULDN'T
WIN.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU JUST GOT
THE LAST REMAINING STOP GAPS OUT
OF CONGRESS.
SO COLOR ME CYNICAL, DEMOCRATS,
WHEN YOU, YOU KNOW, TALK ABOUT
FOLKS LIKE MEYER BEING THE LAST
THING REMAINING AND THEN YOU
DON'T DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU COULD
TO HELP HIM STAY THERE.
YOU ASK FOLKS LIKE ME TO CROSS
PARTY LINES AND VOTE FOR BIDEN,
WHICH I DID, LOTS OF US DID
BECAUSE WE PUT COUNTRY OVER
PARTY.
>> MADE THE DIFFERENCE IN SOME
SWING STATES.
>> THE FAVOR HAS NOT BEEN